أحاول أن أجرب سماعات أذن متعرجة يقومون
بترجمة مباشرة من سنة إلى
أخرى وأنا هنا مع الرئيس التنفيذي
ومؤسس الشركة ،
لذا سأجربها معك ، مشهد رائع في برشلونة ،
ذهبنا إلى مطعم رائع حقًا
الليلة الماضية وكان لدي عدد قليل من أكثر ما أريد أن يكون
مطعمًا
رائعًا ، Ania bhaiya تقريبًا هناك
يمشي معي عبر ما يحدث هنا ،
فأنت بحاجة إلى إقران سماعات الأذن
بالهاتف بمجرد تشغيل الميكروفون
للسماح لك بالبقاء ويمكنك وضعه
الهاتف في جيبك وتحدث فقط
وستلتقط سماعات الأذن ما
تقوله وما هو الاتصال ،
فهناك الكثير من الإشارات المختلفة التي
تستخدم بيانات Wi-Fi 3G LTE Bluetooth
بالطبع جودة cuando el joven
للتلفزيون السوري  فافوريتا عندما كنت
شابًا
متزوجًا من estas casado ، فقلت هل أنت متزوج ،
فهل هذه الترجمة الفورية أو
الترجمة المتتالية ، إذن ،
فالنسخة الأولى تنتظر في الواقع
حتى تنتهي من التحدث قبل أن
تترجم ag  إن الفكرة الكاملة عن
قطع الأذن في سماعات الأذن هي
خلق تجربة أكثر طبيعية ،
أضع الهاتف في جيبي ونحن نتحدث فقط
مع بعضنا البعض عندما نتحدث
كثيرًا عما نفعله حقًا
منظمة ، فكيف
تحسب تقنيتك تلك المهارات اللغوية البشرية الطبيعية جدًا
أو عدم وجودها حتى بالنسبة
لي أتحدث بسرعة وأغمغم
أحيانًا نستخدم كلمات حشو كما
تعلمون أيًا كانت
أنظمة الترجمة هذه تتقدم أيضًا
أو تبدأ في استخدام التعلم الآلي
تكتيكات يمكن أن تلتقط ما يحدث
وتصفية ذلك فال عندما تعتقد أن
هذا سيكون في السوق خلال
الأسابيع الستة إلى الثمانية القادمة ،
سيبدأ الاختبار التجريبي في الشحن هذا الصيف
أنت
[موسيقى]